c'est fin février que le tournage du
biopic très attendu au tour de grégory
lemarchal s'est achevée après un peu
plus d'un mois de tournage ce long
métrage retraçant l'histoire vraie de ce
candidat de la star academy devenu une
star grâce à sa voix d'ange disparu en
2007 deux suites de la mucoviscidose va
prochainement être diffusée sur tf1 au
casting dans le rôle de grégory le jeune
mickaël lumière un comédien jusque là
inconnu mais dont la ressemblance avec
le chanteur est troublante
du côté des parents du chanteur pierre
et lens lemarchal très impliqué
publiquement dans le combat contre la
mucoviscidose ce sont les comédiens
odile vuillemin et arnaud ducret qui se
glisseront dans la peau de ses
personnages
quant à la comédienne candice duflot
elle interprétera le rôle de karine
ferri l'animatrice qui était à l'époque
en couple avec le chanteur enfin pour
camper l'inimitable nikos la production
a décidé de prendre nikos lui même qui
jouera dans son propre rôle
un tournage qui l'a replongée en 2004 je
ne retiens qu'une chose l'impression que
grégory était là près de nous sur le
tournage dans ce studio de la plaine
saint denis qu'il connaissait si bien si
tout semble plutôt fidèle à la réalité
ce n'est pourtant pas le mythique
château de dammarie les lys qui a servi
de lieu de tournage au film et à la
place est une bâtisse située à chambéry
assez ressemblante que les fans pourront
retrouver dans ce film intitulé pourquoi
je vis ce téléfilm évènement est
actuellement en montage et devrait être
diffusée dans les semaines à venir sur
tf1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tél
le papa de grégory et bien sûr eu on a
rencontré ses parents sa soeur
ouais voilà donc oui on a essayé de deux
bars s'est rapprochée un peu de ce
qu'ils avaient vécu et ses deux pas de
comprendre mais c'est sur le tournage
c'était c'était non c'était son père sa
maman est pas beaucoup venus d'accord là
des moments très précis parce que je
pense que c'est difficile mais c'est
l'été pour aussi pour pierre mais ils
avaient envie sur certaines choses qu'on
ne soit pas à côté quoi et en temps à
autre sur les problèmes de la
mucoviscidose la maladie il voulait que
les choses soient assez qu'on conçoit
pas à côté parce qu'en plus ils ont
maintenant une association il voit là il
est plein de personnes atteints de
mucoviscidose sont ancrées de maisons
pour justement aider les gens à à
avancer et c'était assez troublant et
mickaël lumière qui en plus d'être un
mec extraordinaire d'une gentillesse et
un mec qui a beaucoup de talent qui est
en amour il était même moi j'étais des
fois il y en a on insiste on a commandé
en simuler on a simulé l'olympia dans un
théâtre à chambéry pour toutes les
prestations de l'impair de grégory et
moi j'étais sur le côté et s'était alors
y avait les musiciens il y avait les
faits d de public tout et tout était mis
en scène et c'était c'était hyper
trouble en quoi c'était très troublant
mais c'est c1 il voulait aussi montrer
c'est un mélange vie un grégory ça une
positivité incroyable il était à une
énergie extraordinaire un mec hyper
gentil un mec drôle et c'est ça raconte
tout ça aussi c'est important et ça
raconte aussi le début c'est à dire
comment ces gens ou mucoviscidose qui
n'était pas très connu à l'époque tout
le gamin est arrivé comme ça mal à
grégory qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on fait
quoi ils sont c'est le vide et donc on
traite aussi de tout ça et de cette voix
extraordinaire qu avec grégory et je
suis extrêmement fier et je tiens à le
dire que j'ai accepté de faire ce ce
tournage parce que j'ai j'avais beaucoup
de respect pour l'artiste c'est ça c'est
un grand chanteur c'est un grand grand
chanteur vocalement d'une vie
extraordinaire aucun grain du gravier
derrière magnifique et c'est aussi pour
ça que j'ai accepté parce que j'avais
beaucoup de respect pour l'artiste mais
alors ça va arriver ça c'est très
attendu sur tf1 je pense ça va faire un
mba en binôme
dans sa et nikos ou reims on comprend
qu'on la nie bonne idée là faut que
c'est une bonne idée à weeds est
troublant dans l'est on a on a repris
les studios de la relation secrète
ah ouais j'ai participé à la chanson
secrète et le lendemain on faisait la
scène ont tourné la scène de la finale
de la star ac c'était c'est c'est ou
c'était troublant cornes et je suis très
fort en plus parce que je le dis mais
michael est un mec super mais quelle
manière dont qu'il initie a que lui pour
jouer ben voilà ça va arriver sur tf1 ça
c'est très très très attendu